je cours
ce sport
eur52 bonheur
visage elle a quand même une vie privée
assez compliqué sa mère est atteinte de
la maladie d'alzheimer sa fiancé
s'appelle nadine alors concernant votre
mère c'est autobiographique
pendant qu'elle était malade vous êtes
parti pendant un an à son chevet dans
l'appartement de votre enfance à
saint-etienne est pas possible de vous
deux vous décollez dalle qua non
non parce que quand on sent quand on
sait pas d'ailleurs cette maladie on ne
sait pas que ça va faire mourir donc je
sais pas sans reste parce qu'on sent que
mais cette maladie en tout cas je fais
que l'eia lâcher prise de la part des
gens qui m'ont et ma mère qui était
plutôt quelqu'un de dur enfin de voilà
qui était un tueur avait lâché donc elle
était menthe et c'est tout ce qu'on a
envie de le prendre
et puis et puis
infirmière quoi une phrase terrible et
on perd la personne mais elle est encore
vivante
oui c'est terrible ce terrible les mots
pour expliquer ça parce que c'est vrai
qu'en de vins les plus là on aurait fait
un deuil elle est là et on se dit tous
les matins on serait rien me suis dit je
vais faire comme tout le monde je vais
faire un petit retour arrière et puis ça
va marcher parce que parce que parfois
ça marche donc taquet pierre pourquoi ça
marche mais parfois ça marche quand elle
est celle des éclairs de lucidité un
moment il y en a plus du tout et puis on
n'a plus du tout quand maman le jour où
ma mère maggie q uoi muriel ouais j'ai
vécu une chose que j'entendais cette
expression le sang qui se glace jamais
jamais connu ça le mali j'ai eu le son
qui s'est glacé
c'est un truc bon voilà donc qui après
n'y a plus jamais ça connectait plus est
la personne n'est plus là et plus alors
voilà le plus là alors à l'issue de
cette aventure tragique vous avez connu
une dépression assez grave
oui oui j'étais très mal quand j'avais
un peu un moment j'étais les yeux au
plafond et je m'en sortirais pas quoi
oui même à malraux sarah diffalah m une
clinique psychiatrique faut pas laisser
comme ça je ça marchait plus
j'étais plus donc on m'a mise à l'eau
bon endroit dans un village là où
j'avais fait ma terminale donc souvenirs
souvenirs peu importe et puis ces voix
là et les gens dont c'est le métier des
psys tout simplement des choses bêtes
comme vous forcer à prendre une douche
en nous disant c'est avec de l'eau
chaude parce que s'activent le sens et
ça voilà des gens des mots mais surtout
ça et après avoir aidé ou un mois et
demi deux cliniques psychiatriques
gg mais j'étais debout voilà on vous a
proposé d'écrire un livre à ce moment là
oui après peu après j'ai commencé à
mettre des mots sur ça je les ennemis
d'ailleurs et et je dirais que ce qui
est intéressant dans cette écriture
parce que la bonne écriture peut-être si
j'ai quelque chose à dire d'intéressant
c'est quand y en a plus du tout censure
l'autocensure temps quelque chose qui
sortait comme ça donc j'ai pu balancer
40 pages qui sont je crois qu'à un
moment c'est ni bien ni pas bien quand
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
comme si le c'est comme si on regardait
docteur et comment y êtes dedans et puis
ça m'a fait aller mieux aussi
ouais ça et un moment c'est drôle parce
que j'ai de belles et mieux et puis j'ai
voulu écrire puisse commencer à regarder
ce que j'écrivais l'art et sensuelle et
là j'ai pu écrire ce que je prenne mon
objectif c'est allé mieux la voir en
fait ce bouquin si vous êtes servi de
thérapie parce que vous dites là ce n
est pas du tout une thérapie pour monter
sur scène il faut aller bien c'est la
plus magnifique des pommades parce que
pommade canton la bobo ça fait ça fait
douze quoi ça fait du bien mais ça ne
guérit pas je ne soigne pas non plus nos
thérapies aussi c'est que vous êtes
délesté de 15 kilos quand même non non
feinte le trafic avec ce poids alors
après on peut dire des chiffres qui font
les gens se foutent peut-être il est
monté très haut là vous êtes monté à la
94 quand même c'est fait j'ai pu un
moment ces kilos de la centaine la wes
masters
parce que je les avais beaucoup
oui j'avais déjà faisait pas rire tous
mes amis d'ailleurs je pense est en
outre en ce qu on appelle cette presqu
île du zéro pour noël ont fait une belle
fête parce que à la fin de l'année on va
fêter le quintal et ça la faisait pas
rire les gens que j'aime je les aime
beaucoup que ça nous faisait pas rire
c'est pas moi c'est que loin j'étais
super bien gaulée j'ai fait 60 kg
jusqu'à 35 ans j'avais encore nickel et
puis c'est qu'ils ne sont pas moins ils
représentent ce qui n'est pas à moi
dedans quand j'enlève j'enlève j'enlève
ils vont partir avec en vous parlez de
vous à l'époque ya quelques années sur
scène vous dites et engoncés dans des
vêtements trop serrés je vais la tête
qui dépassait avec la coupe la plus
courte possible
espèce de machine de guerre quoi
qu'est-ce que c'est ce visage carré ses
cheveux courts cette fille qui est comme
ça qui est finie joli ni page avis
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
colombienne un boulot à faire quand je
vois les images aujourd'hui je me dis
que j'ai un peu bosser que mieux ça va
très bien le pire c'est moi par ma mère
bien là on vous a connu plus vous êtes
vous êtes délester aussi de beaucoup de
choses vous aviez des pièces en pics et
des amplis de livres en plus de fringues
brest 10 objets mais les objets les dix
objets que j'ai chez moi place était pas
très bibelots mais quand même les
disques des jeux c'est pourquoi ils sont
là ils ont un sens donc c'est pas mal et
l'appartement où il avait vendu il est
arrivé en retard au mans vous disiez
tant pis j'ai habité chez line renaud au
seattle n'importe où
moi aussi je me suis dit ça dit non mais
mal foutu à la porte il était autour de
la pâte à saint germain en sixième mais
m² 159 on était important de 150 m²
bâtonnier cela m me dis lui
confectionnant tous les biens c'est très
gentil pour la note vous dit puisque tu
as dit me dit vous êtes vous les voulez
vous étiez parfait tous les deux donc je
ne sais pas les deux sûrement mois voilà
sa coupe et donc son périmètre 95 et tu
le vends combien suivant le prix qui
coûte c'est à dire
2 millions d'euros 2 millions d'euros
donc si quelqu'un d'intéressé séquelles
rue c'est je suis sûr que les gens
regardent bien sud est terry chéri 1 86e
mais pauvre tous se mettre à plusieurs
après quoi c'est un peu quand on est aux
normes et donc 2 millions mais tu est
négociable ou pas deux millions c'est ce
que ça coûte donc voilà deux millions il
ya de terrain miné
vous enlevez tous les gars je m'en fous
c'est clair ces dominos est très bien
c'est de ce bruit on s'est surpris du
tout en silence la maison mais les
charges pas trop de charges etc les
bénéfices de ta pièce tu sais ce qu'ils
te faire y a plus qu'à attendre petite
vingtaine d'années machete l'a pas bien
alors dans au secours lisa l'héroïne
bisexuelle et challans est passé comme
une lettre à la poste sur les gens que
vous avez dit ça sur scène vous dit ma
fiancée s'appelle nadine va pas choquer
les gens pas sauter en l'air
non alors moi je vais être vraiment
honnête c'est que quand un moment quand
il fallait que cette fille ou une fois
qu'on avait fait rentrer la mère c'est
même la seule fallait bien qu'elle ait
la vie privée et la plus pire n'était
plus avec moi jusqu'à moment il n'a plus
pu écrire avec mal an j'étais seul je me
suis dit bon évidemment l'été avec un
mec et j'étais avec roger louret mon
metteur en scène et je lui dis c'était
qu'une femme est ce que c'est pas plus
drôle plus drôle surtout ceux dans la
fiction après savoir si lisa c'est comme
moi on peut se poser la question
vous posez la question moi je la poserai
pas parce que comme vous sachiez
discrétion légendaire tout le monde le
sait dans ce pays désormais oui dans
certaines émissions tu d'une pudeur ne
l'imposé pas je ne pose pas mais vous la
posez pas nous l'imposé pas et
j'apprécie parce que ça fait plusieurs
fois que je viens
c'est plusieurs fois par soir sur les
terrains voilà peut-être les gens sont
mal à l'aise mais puisque vous me
l'imposé pas je vais vous répondre
c'est que je prends l'amour là où il est
la vie est très courte j'imagine que
pour vous l'être humain est un être
humain est plus important que le sexe
l'amour
ceci étant je vais déclarer je sait
depuis toujours que je finirais ma vie
avec un homme
oui j'ai dit ça je et bien c'est pas
bien parce que c'est déjà encore me
foutrait je sais rien je sais rien je
suis je sais rien je sais rien je sais
rien mais dont cosco est un gros succès
le dvd va cartonner et pourtant
récemment on vous a beaucoup entendu
vous vous plaindre dans les médias de ce
que personne vous propose deux films au
cinéma
vous dites on ne désire pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que j'ai qui leur déplaît
d'ailleurs est-ce que je suis trop
blonde est ce que je suis trop gros
c'est ce que j'ai le menton trop trop
carré parce que quand on est populaire
c'est une constatation est un bonheur
mais depuis maintenant plus de quinze
ans l'une des plus populaires peut-être
suffi dans la vérité et c'est vrai je
n'ai pas de proposition mais pas un
point qui fait qu'au début on dit bon
ben c'est pas grave
et puis d'ailleurs mais au début puis
après aussi on dit c'est pas grave on
dit plus on aide parce qu'on a de
l'orgueil donc on dit que ceux ci
veulent pas de moi une menace at on bien
puisque toute façon moi non plus je veux
pas de grain fini par se trahir et voilà
et puis et puis on peut aussi un moment
s'est arrêtée puis se dire je
si j'enlève l'orgueil moi je me suis dit
si tu enlèves l'orgueil muriel qu'est ce
que ça fait et j'ai pleuré et j'ai
pleuré mais vraiment ce que je me suis
dit à ce point là rien ne proposer
pourquoi depuis le dante a pas écrit est
ton truc sur mesure de faire des autres
si ça ne veut pas dire hey hey je vais
déjà me mettre des gens à dos si je veux
en ferrain vu parfois ce que je peux
voir je pense que je peux en écrire un
par mois la passion c'est le problème de
faire un film
moi c'est le désir si on désire les
autres 60 les gens ne savent pas mais
peut-être que j'aurais dû plus le dire
mais j'ai fait le conservatoire je pense
que je vais avoir un parcours de
comédienne puis se trouve que j'avais
appris avec michel bouquet oui enfin je
vois moi je ne sais pas je fais c'est du
moins le macho mais jamais de ma vie je
sais ça et il se trouve que je le fais
plus que ça ma façon c'était ça ou rien
j'avais 15 ans et vous avez reçu que des
scénarios vous dites avec des rôles
pitoyable de camionneuse qui jure équipe
est enfin pas des trucs qui revint
scénario à peine un quart et un truc
mais donc encore une fois là je suis
dans la vérité je dis que ça me fait de
la peine
je dis clairement je dis que je veux
bien je dis encore d'autant plus de
liant d'autant plus que le one man show
celui là était différent le prochain je
n'ai même pas sur le rhin et c'est vrai
que si je suis désirer dans ce métier je
suis sûr que même mâchoire deviendront
un peu plus voilà un peu plus
triangulaire et que cela puisque je
dirais super en ce moment ça va bien et
qu'on dira tiens ses deux fils et elle
va bien quand elle est sympa à carapace
elle n'y a pas de rien parce que ça dit
quoi d'être désiré c'est un moment où
une famille même pas je parle pas d'une
famille de cinq six personnes
mais la famille de ce métier qu'ils
aient envie qu'ils me prennent dans
leurs bras avant ces jeunes et j'ai fait
ce métier c'est qu'on l'ait vraiment
l'aimer mais motivation mais je me
disais un jour ce sera la plus molière
au valdonnez moi vivons tous me regarde
et puis je vais leur dire merci
vous êtes ma famille puis vous dis merci
c'est grâce à vous j'aimerais aider à
vivre
et puis ça arrive jamais jamais donc
jeudi une famille parce que pas de
parents pas d'enfant il famille dans le
non mais voyez ce que j'ai donc bon bah
si ça doit être comme ça ça ira et
surtout très important mais vraiment
c'est pas une plainte
c'est juste que j'ai le droit d recèle
aussi même si j'ai vécu c'est pendant
ces quinze ans beaucoup de beaucoup de
bobos 6 heures si beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour et comment que j'aime
ce public parce que il a été tellement
là et que c'est ça m'a aidé à tenir
aussi seul